- Welcome back everybody.
We are here with The Chicks.
Give it up!
(audience cheering)
So The Chicks and I are
all musicians, of course,
that means you'd think we'd be good
at distinguishing sounds of common items,
some of which we hear every day.
You'd think, but I am horrible at it.
And we're gonna find out
if they're horrible as well
with another round of A Quiet Case.
♪ A quiet case ♪
- You go ahead, Jessi Collins,
with the sexy little voice.
Okay. Team I, mine sounds different today.
Teams are The Chicks,
Natalie, Martie, and Emily
versus the winner, me.
So, we need a host.
I didn't wanna just beat a couple of 'em.
I wanted to beat all of them at once.
It's just who I am innately.
So everybody please welcome the host
of "American Ninja Warrior"
which returns to NBC starting tonight,
friend of the show and all
around great guy, Matt Iseman.
(audience cheering)
- How are you?
- I am doing so great. I'm
coming off five all-nighters.
We just finished the show. So I'm loopy.
- So should we all start
drinking now? Is this the, like?
- You haven't started?
- I am behind. I'm like, well,
it's great to see you again.
- [Matt] Thank you, Kelly.
- Do you wanna let us know
how and I'm gonna lose?
- So this is how it works.
You can see, we have eight cases here.
Now, inside these cases
are eight everyday items.
- Ugh.
- You teams will take
turns choosing a case
and guessing the item inside.
But if you're wrong.
If you're wrong.
- Shut up.
- [Matt] The other team
will get a chance--
- I am offended.
- To steal. A cool prize is on the line.
The Chicks are playing for the
right side of the audience.
And Kelly's playing for the left.
- Don't you!
- Good luck, left.
- Don't you, don't you put that on me!
- If The Chicks win, though,
you will be immortalized,
getting your photo on the
Blake Shelton Wall of Champions
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
- Who cares? It's a dumb wall.
- Honestly, who better to host a game
called the quiet case than me?
(everyone laughing)
All right, we are up.
Kelly is such a good host that
she demanded she goes first.
So Kelly.
- Yeah.
- [Matt] Choose your case.
- Yeah, it's my show.
Okay. I say two.
- [Matt] Two?
- Two.
Two. See, you felt
strong. You felt strong.
Come on, Clarkson.
- I could see Natalie
trying to side eye the case,
but we are on it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Now here we go, listen carefully.
- [Kelly] Closing my eyes. Okay.
- Here it is.
- Oh.
Is that a slinky?
(screams)
- Oh my goodness. It is a metal slinky.
(audience cheering)
- You're shocked, aren't you?
- I am.
Kelly, I think that's the first
one you've got it correct--
- [Kelly] I think it's the first one.
- In 92 times of playing this game.
- I am so shocked right
now. I feel confident!
You're going down.
(everyone laughing)
- [Matt] Trash talking Kelly. Be careful.
- Oh my gosh. Okay.
- All right Chicks. You
see how the game is played,
now it's your turn. Choose a case.
- Three.
- [Matt] Okay.
- 'Cause there's three of us. Three.
- Three.
- I'm gonna listen so good. I
feel it's my day. It's my day.
- Are you ready?
Listen carefully.
- Is it a card shuffle?
- What?
- A card shuffle?
- What is it, ladies?
- Okay, go ahead. No, it's not right.
- After Kelly, a brush.
- Oh my God!
(everyone cheering)
It is a hairbrush.
- What!
- [Matt] Well done!
- Good job, Emily.
- How did you get a card shuffle?
- [Emily] That was you.
- [Martie] I did.
- I have legit guessed hairbrush
in this game 9,000 times
and it has never happened,
and I didn't get that win?
- I saw them choosing it.
We felt, we felt that it
was going to be yours.
- I see you, God!
- [Matt] Kelly, your choice.
- So bitter. Eight.
I can't believe hairbrush was one.
I'm so mad right now
that I didn't get that.
- Here we go. Are you ready?
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Let me make it work.
- Are you gonna what? When?
- Oh, I think it sounds like a typewriter.
No no no, I'm not gonna say a typewriter,
I'm not gonna didn't say typewriter.
- A typewriter is incorrect.
Chicks, you have a chance to
take the lead and steal this.
- That's a rotary telephone.
- [Matt] Oh my God!
- Oh!
- Hello? Hello?
- I had a rotary.
- You're too young.
- I, no! We had a rotary! I had a rotary.
- Chicks, and this is the last one.
- Isn't the last one worth 10 points?
- You guys could really run
away with this contest, ladies.
Which case would you like?
- You pick.
- Five.
- Five. Good as five.
- I almost went five.
- [Matt] It's history on
the line. Are you ready?
- [Kelly] Oh, I, I.
- Gotta be.
- I know what this is.
I know what it is! I think.
Watch me be way wrong.
- For 10 points, and the greatest victory
in the history of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show",
Blake Shelton himself may write
a song about this victory.
- [Kelly] No, don't do
it, don't, keep talking.
Oh, oh, what's your
guess? What's your guess?
- Keys.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's what I
thought. Oh my God, I was right!
- The Chicks had the keys!
- [Kelly] That's what I thought it was.
- Ladies and gentlemen,
it is the greatest victory
in the history of "The Kelly
Clarkson Show", The Chicks win!
(audience cheering)
- All right, but everyone is a winner here
you know, except for me.
As I mentioned earlier,
The Chicks 2022 tour
with special guests Patty
Griffin and Jenny Lewis,
kicks off next week and
tickets are on sale now.
Don't be a fool, go get some tickets.
But everyone in the audience
is getting a pair of tickets
to show of your choice.
Any show of your choice.
(audience cheering)
Which is exciting.
And
it's exciting. It's exciting.
And because The Chicks won, their photos
will be put up on the
stupid Blake Shelton,
I can't stand that name,
Blake Shelton Wall of Champions
Who Beat Kelly Clarkson,
whatever.
You're gonna look beautiful
on the wall, whatever.
- Can we get the name renamed?
Can we have the wall renamed after us?
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- We are the biggest winners.
- [Kelly] You're the biggest winner.
- Thank you.
- We are now officially changing the name.
Take that Blake Shelton,
to The Chicks Wall of People
Who Beat Kelly Clarkson.
This turned out to be my favorite game.